bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
vidéo dédiée à la série de boba fett et
notamment sa fin il y a des choses
plutôt intéressant à traiter des choses
se mettent en place pour la suite et je
vous propose de voir ça ensemble en tout
cas je suis très content de reparler de
star wars je vous avoue que ça
commençait à me manquer un petit peu et
franchement l'avenir semble plutôt
prometteur donc voilà bref ne tardons
pas commençons tout d'abord il faut que
nous re contextualise ont un petit peu
la situation nous sommes poste mandat
lauriane saison 2 beaucoup parlent du
fait que la série boba fett est une
sorte de mandat lauriane 2.5 et
franchement bas je trouve pas ça mais
dix ans de dire ça en fait
personnellement je vois vraiment boba
fett comme la série qui va permettre de
transitionner mandaloriennes saison 2 et
mandaloriennes saison 3 est en même
temps permettent de répondre au retour
de l'ex chasseur de primes qui était
réapparu dans la saison 10 ils sont en
train de relancer le développement de
l'univers et perso je trouve ça plutôt
sympa ce n'est pas juste ils sortent une
production pour combler un trou dans le
passé puis on revient dans une période
plus récente avec une autre production
là on ressent vraiment le désir de
recréer une continuité et une histoire
où tout est interconnecté boba fett a
des liens avec d'inge arin d'inge arina
lui même des liens avec gros goût gros
goût qui a des liens avec ahsoka et luc
donc ils sont amenés à tous à terre agir
ensemble et perso je pense que l'on va
continuer dans cette direction on a eu
vent de dos saisons 1 et 2 puis la série
boba fett il est fort probable que
mandaloriennes saison 3 soit la
prochaine oeuvre à sortir est dedans
nous pourrions retrouver bon nombre de
personnages puis pour la série à saucats
certainement aussi bref les crossover ne
sont pas terminées néanmoins je mets
quand même un point de réserve pour boba
fett car je trouve intrigant de l'avoir
fait devenir un damier car en tant que
nouveaux dirigeants il ne peut plus
intervenir comme avant ces péripéties
avec phoenix end les ont cloué sur
tatouine quitter son royaume pour aller
vagabonder dans l'espace c'est un risque
derrière de le perdre enfin bon juste
pour dire que je pense que cette
nouvelle situation freinerait
possiblement les interactions avec boba
fett à part s'il intrigue se déroule sur
tatouine bourg en tout cas c'est quand
même une belle évolution pour boba fett
et j'ai bien aimé le délire avec les
tuskens bon maintenant il est temps de
parler de gros goût et de son choix déjà
ce choix permet de répondre à
l'incohérence et le questionnement que
on se faisait pour beaucoup concernant
le fait que ben solo était censé être le
premier élève de l'académie de luxe
puisque gros goût a choisi la côte de
maille cela signifie qu'il ne sera pas
le premier élève de l'udc et quelques
années plus tard ben alias le future cac
et lorraine le sera d'ailleurs ce choix
amène quelques éléments intéressants
déjà cela annonce clairement la couleur
pour mandat lauriane saison 3 je pense
personnellement que faire avancer gros
goût dans la série boba fett avec cet
entraînement aux côtés de luc et ce
fameux choix va nous permettre de ne pas
avoir ces moments là dans la saison 3
tout comme pour jean jouines le
mandalorien et gros go étaient tous les
deux perdus et divisé pendant les
événements de boba fett et maintenant
qu'ils sont réunis et qu'ils ont fait
leur choix ils sont fin prêts pour
affronter les événement de la saison 3
de mandat lauriane gros goût va
continuer d'évoluer et utiliser la force
la poste au logis nous l'a prouvé il
existe des utilisateurs de la force bien
qu'il ne soit ni des jedi ni décide
ensuite il est clair d'annoncer que
mandaloriennes saison 3 va complètement
plongé dans le coeur de l'histoire des
mandaloriens l'épisode 5 de boba fett
nous l'a clairement fait comprendre à
terme le but serait une sorte de
renaissance du peuple mandaloriens qui
sont dispersés à travers toute la
galaxie jean jouines va d'ailleurs
devoir se racheter pour ses fautes en
tant que le mandalorien comme le fait
d'avoir déjà montré sa tête et ce genre
de quête va permettre de mieux
appréhender la culture mandaloriennes et
son histoire puis maintenant que jean
jouines a rencontré un jedi sa quête est
désormais terminé l'armure hier l'ue a
demandé d'aider les mandaloriens a
ressuscité le clan quête qu'il fera
après en avoir terminé avec son exil
d'ailleurs le sabre noir c'est
exactement pareil c'est le vestige des
mandaloriens par excellence donc on
retrouve encore une fois tout ce côté
historique surtout que jean jouines va
devoir apprendre à le maîtriser sans
oublier évidemment les dires de l'armure
hier mandaloriennes qui a pris le temps
d'expliquer l'histoire des mandaloriens
avec la grande purge ou également
l'origine du darksiders avec tard vise
là le premier jedi mandaloriens dont je
vous avais déjà parlé dans une vidéo
précédente bref voilà tous les sports à
croire que la saison 3 de mandat
lauriane va nous plonger dans le coeur
du problème des mandaloriens et de leur
histoire néanmoins il ne faut pas
oublier également tout l'aspect
politique la fin de mandat lauriane
saison 2 reste toujours très importante
le fait que jean jouines possède le
sabre noir va diviser les mandaloriens
et nous en avons déjà eu la preuve deux
fois tout d'abord par le biais de pas
vis là le descendant de tahar vise la
lui même le créateur du sabre noir
ce dernier nous a bien fait comprendre
qu'il n'approuvait pas que dean soit en
possession du sabre déjà car il est le
descendant légitime de tardi cela et qu
en plus dean est devenu un apostat pour
avoir enfreint certaines règles du credo
pas symbolise d'ailleurs les
mandaloriens aux vieilles traditions et
de l'autre côté nous avons beau catane
qui symbolise l'autre catégorie de
mandaloriens un peu plus libre sur les
règles cette dernière est obnubilé par
le sabre noir car elle sait que celle
artefacts qui va lui permettre de régner
sur mandalore son objectif ultime
malheureusement mando lui a retiré cette
opportunité en vainquant guidone en
combat singulier
ce qui fait qu'il est devenu le légitime
possesseurs du sabre noir et c'est
d'ailleurs plutôt marrant car nous ne
savons pas ce qui s'est passé depuis la
fin de la saison de demande à laurianne
nous retrouvons simplement dean jarring
en train d'effectuer une chasse avec le
sabre dans l'épisode 5 de boba fett
pourtant il est clair que hbo catane n'a
pas dû en rester là ok guider on est
vaincue et elle a récupéré son vaisseau
mais l'objectif principal était le sabre
noir ils ont dû passer un accord ou
échanger sur la situation mais nous ne
savons pas encore ce qui en a découlé et
aussi c'est l'un des points qui
m'intrigue le plus à chaque fois on en a
déjà pas mal parler mais le cas de guy
dionne n'est pas à prendre à la légère
surtout campus dean là épargnée donc il
est toujours le mandalorien nous a fait
croire qu'il serait exécuté par la
république mail armurière émettent un
doute cela confirme son retour pour moi
dans la saison 3 surtout qu'il était
prévu que guy des hommes reviennent pour
cette troisième saison est d'ailleurs
point que je trouve très intéressant
c'est que contrairement à jean jouines
guider homme sait manier le sabre noir
guide est honnête un personnage qui
cache de nombreux secrets il est très au
fait des coutumes mandaloriennes il est
devenu mof dans le plus grand des
secrets alors que l'empiré normalement
tomber on se doute que c'est lié à la
naissance du premier ordre et voilà et
du coup le fait de nous montrer que dean
jarring à l'air a utilisé le sabre et
même pas vis là le descendant de tahar
vise la lui même et bien cela
sous-entend qu'il ya quelque chose
derrière que l'on ne sait pas encore en
réalité nous ne savons pas grand-chose
du sabre noir nous l'avons juste vu
passer de main en main mais il se
pourrait qu'ils cachent de nombreux
secrets que nous ne savons pas encore un
point qui sera très certainement amené
dans la saison 3 mais bref je vous
invite clairement avoir ma vidéo trois
théories sur mandaloriennes saison 3 car
franchement elle est toujours autant
d'actualité
la série de boba fett n'a pas
spécialement fait avancer beaucoup de
choses mais a permis de valider pas mal
d'éléments que nous attendions comme par
exemple l'entraînement de gros goût le
cas du premier élève de l'udc et c'est
quoi ce genre de choses donc si vous
voulez des théories sur mamda lauriane
saison 3 voilà vous savez où aller je
vous conseille fortement de voir cette
vidéo je suis pas sûr que répéter
mot-à-mot maintenant dans cette vidéo ce
que j'avais dit à l'époque soit la
meilleure des idées en vrai la vidéo est
plutôt courte j'en suis désolé je
voulais marquer le coup pour la fin de
boba fett car cela fait longtemps qu'on
a pas parlé de star wars et franchement
ça me manquait parce que c'est l'un des
sujets que j'adore néanmoins la série
boba fett amène plus de confirmation que
de réelles nouvelles questions pour
l'avenir et le futur on attend désormais
de pied ferme mandaloriennes saison 3 là
série sur ahsoka devraient également
être intéressantes je pense d'ailleurs
que boba fett nous là un petit peu teasé
cette série sur ahsoka notamment avec le
passage où l'udc demande à saucats si
justement il aura l'occasion de la
revoir ahsoka possède une grande quête
retrouver ezra et cela promet de belles
choses et possiblement de nouveau
crossover pour le futur pour le moment
on va se concentrer sur la série dédiée
à obi wan kenobi qui sort bientôt et vu
la nouvelle direction que prend star
wars on remarque qu'il ya quand même
deux branches significative parmi les
séries nous avons la branche qui traite
de la période entre l'épisode 6 et
l'épisode 7 donc entre la trilogie la
poste au logis donc avec mandat lauriane
ahsoka boba fett rodgers of the republic
etc etc puis dans l'autre branche nous
avons des oeuvres qui se concentre plus
sur la période entre l'épisode iii et iv
donc la prélogie et la trilogie avec
notamment la série sur obi-wan celle sur
kassian en dehors ou encore celle sur
l'endos vu que mandaloriennes boba fett
et ahsoka nous a prouvé que les
personnages pouvaient être reliés peu
importe la série il n'est pas impossible
je pense que nous retrouvions le même
procédé pour les séries qui traite de la
période entre l'épisode 3 et 4 bref on
va s'arrêter là ça fait du bien de faire
le point si la vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit pouce
bleu un commentaire sur ce que vous avez
pensé de la série et puis à vous abonner
c'est très important et puis écouté que
le lionheart sont avec vous c'était
argot rock allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]